it's it's interesting what you just said
for example how can I apply what I
learned in a classroom in what is the
structure how can we get involved there
are so many ways that people can get
involved and another question is for
example or how if someone is spending
four years in a classroom learning
learning learning after your fourth year
you are a graduate from Columbia
University and you are off so what
what's next I see a lot of people in
Africa a lot of students or graduate
from Harvard from year from so many
different places who are doing this and
that a lot of projects the challenges I
think have in my opinion pin these we
know and we're the experts in a place
like Wanda or like Burundi my time are
chrome university has been crucial in so
many ways learning how to listen observe
and figure out what what is actually
needed for someone I would like to help
for example and that was a great
experience my other greatest teachers
have frankly been the poor people we
serve in Burundi who walk around
barefoot Mannering kid was in very
managed to think about what can I do
what can I actually teach them and if
you actually sit down with them eat what
they are eating which is not always good
because that's the reason why they are
severely malnourished in the feel
exactly the pain they actually have to
under on a daily basis in the you roll
innocent you go back anything huh now I
learned in school how can I actually
apply that in the heavy composition with
all the people around me and then do
something good but what is that
something good
it's extremely important to go to a
place like Burundi not as an expert
first first as a listener and have a
conversation with people because I think
there are a lot of resources really
wasted waste over the world there's a
reason why they're there is so much
program so a lot of programs and just
wonder why how come they're wave so many
NGOs how come that we have so many
organizations and yet new problems are
accumulating growing exponentially what
are we doing wrong at least these are
real fundamental questions what I think
we are doing wrong we go to a place even
or in our backyard as experts and we do
not ask people around in our bucket what
exactly they think of us or what the
needs are so education never ends it's a
we you know we learning is a process is
a lifetime thing and as long as you know
students who graduate or even faculty
members can go to a place only have a
project and say look I like this I'm
going to do it and you make sure that
when you are doing something it doesn't
die when you leave you have to work with
people in the understand exactly that
the time we're spending the resources
you are see what you are spending over
there are going to keep growing so I
think there is a lot we can do enter and
quite a lot of NGOs really have failed
miserably for that reason you go to a
place like bromley hundreds of NGOs we
bump into so many of them and they say
well so we are working in a small
village of kabuto and say oh we are
working over there it turns out it's
around where we are but they don't even
know what its waste or north or we're
just doing business sitting the capital
of Burundi bujumbura and you wonder what
is going on but we have our future it
works you know with all these students
and college
students and medical students and others
decided to just go and set up tents
which is a wonderful when you are there
for just two days or three nights not
for a year and be with people and learn
exactly from them so it's been a really
wonderful in with soul such as you know
two years with solar resources we've
done so much in in one year the first
day of operation more than 33,000
patients treated other clinic and it's
because we you know we have you know try
to get people i'm going to say look
let's work with them let's make you know
work with people what making breaks
because we don't have resources and they
learn from us we learn from them that
are we been teaching it at Judy